monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
bonjour Nous achetons ce matin les
auditions dans le cadre de la commission
d'enquête sur le coût de la vie sur les
territoires
articles 73 articles 74 les
collectivités territoriales relevant de
l'article des articles 73 et 74 je
remplace monsieur Guillaume vilté notre
président qui a un empêchement nous
entendons aujourd'hui Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique monsieur le ministre je
vous remercie je vous souhaite bien sûr
la bienvenue et je vous remercie de
prendre le temps de répondre à notre
invitation je vais vous passer la parole
pour une intervention liminaire
s'ensuivra les questions de nos
collègues sous forme d'échange avec des
questions et des réponses et bien sûr a
commencé par les questions de notre
rapporteur je vous remercie également
monsieur le ministre de nous déclarer
tout autre intérêt public ou privé la
nature a influencé vos déclarations
auparavant je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires imposent
aux personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité rien toute la vérité
rien que la vérité je vous invite donc
monsieur le ministre alevé la main
droite et à dire je le jure je le jure
monsieur le Président merci je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs je suis
très heureux de vous retrouver ce matin
pour répondre aux questions de la
commission d'enquête sur une priorité du
gouvernement qui est la vie chère en
outre-mer je voudrais commencer par une
évidence la vie est chère dans les îles
dans toutes les îles quelle qu'elle soit
et quel que soit la nation à laquelle
elles appartiennent
elle est chère parce que l'éloignement
l'isolement les difficultés de
développement économique l'absence de
marché intérieur significatif rendre
tous les produits plus chers et la vie
économique plus difficile
j'étais il y a deux semaines en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique ce séjour
m'a permis d'échanger avec les acteurs
locaux de dresser des constats plus
précis qui vont me permettre de répondre
plus précisément aux questions et de
tirer aussi un certain nombre
d'enseignements pratiques pour les
années à venir
je le disais la vie chère est une
réalité dans les territoires
ultramarins quand on regarde les écarts
de prix à la consommation ils sont
significatifs par rapport à l'Hexagone
7% de différence de prix entre
l'hexagone et la France à la Réunion et
à Mayotte 12% aux Antilles en Guyane par
rapport à l'Hexagone c'est donc des
écarts de prix qui sont très
significatifs les raisons je les ai
données je vais les reprendre un peu
plus longuement d'abord l'éloignement
avec des coûts de transport à l'import
comme à l'export en particulier dans les
territoires les plus isolés accumulent
l'intermédiaires qui à chaque fois
représente des commissions et donc des
prix plus élevés et une sensibilité très
forte à la variation des prix
énergétiques qui sont utilisés dans les
moyens de transport
en deuxième lieu c'est la fiscalité qui
mérite j'y reviendrai d'être refondu
avec un octroi de mer qui renchérit les
prix des biens jusqu'à plus 5% et qui
constituent le premier poste de coût
dans les frais d'approche des produits
importés je donne des exemples très
concrets la farine elle est axée à 30% à
l'octroi de mer en Martinique et en
Guadeloupe alors que le taux de TVA dans
l'Hexagone est à 5,5% sur la farine soit
24,5% d'écart sur la seule fiscalité
pour un paquet de farine deuxième
exemple qui m'a d'ailleurs été cité très
souvent parce que c'est un des produits
de base de l'alimentation en Martinique
comme dans beaucoup d'autres endroits
dans l'Hexagone c'est le riz 20%
d'octroi de mer alors que chacun sait
que les rizières ne pululent pas en
Martinique donc tout cela représente des
surcoûts qui sont extraordinairement
important
la troisième raison c'est les trois
tests des marchés je l'ai vu comme
ministre de l'Économie je l'ai vu
peut-être encore plus lorsque j'étais
ministre de l'Agriculture qui fait que
le seuil de rentabilité est extrêmement
difficile à atteindre pour les
producteurs et les incitent à augmenter
les prix cela fait 10 ans qu'on parle au
moins pour ce que j'en connais de
l'autonomie des producteurs à la
Martinique en Guadeloupe à la Réunion ou
dans les autres territoires et
départements d'outre-mer la réalité
c'est que cela suppose d'avoir un marché
plus important pour faire baisser le
seuil de rentabilité faire baisser le
seul rentabilité des intrants qui
eux-mêmes ont fortement augmenté or la
réalité que c'est beaucoup plus complexe
sur les territoires plus petits
je voudrais néanmoins introduire deux
nuances à ce constat qui me paraît
incontestable personne ne peut nier que
la vie est plus chère dans les
départements et les régions d'outre-mer
la première nuance c'est que l'inflation
en 2022 a été moindre que dans le reste
du pays avec une inflation moyenne de
plus 4,9% c'est-à-dire un point de moins
que le niveau national et cela notamment
en raison des mesures qui ont été prises
par le gouvernement la deuxième nuance
que je voudrais introduire c'est que
nous avons des leviers et pouvoirs
publics pour limiter l'ampleur de ce
phénomène de vie cher et ses
conséquences pour les consommateurs
fragiles et que c'est levier il faut
évidemment les utiliser
le premier levier c'est le développement
de l'économie locale pour augmenter
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes je
voudrais insister sur le fait que ce
développement de communes locales doit
sortir des sentiers battus qui parfois
se limitent exclusivement au tourisme ou
à l'agriculture ce sont évidemment des
vecteurs de développement économique
important mais j'étais très frappé de
voir que en Martinique et en Guadeloupe
d'autres projets très structurants sont
en train de voir le jour dans le secteur
industriel dans le secteur des
transports avec l'agrandissement des
deux ports de la Martinique et de la
Guadeloupe qui créent des emplois à plus
forte valeur ajoutée donc qui permettent
d'apporter une réponse sous forme de
travail et de travail mieux rémunéré à
nos compatriotes de ces départements je
crois donc qu'il faut que nous
élargissions la question du
développement économique local au sol
filières qui sont régulièrement
mentionnés parce qu'il y a des
potentiels extra dans ces territoires
qui sont parfois sous-utilisés de ce
point de vue là je tiens à dire que le
projet de loi industrie verte doit
comporter des dispositions pour
l'outre-mer et doit permettre de
dynamiser l'industrie dans ces
territoires pour produire des biens à
forte valeur ajoutée je ne vois pourquoi
la logique que nous développons dans
l'Hexagone et qui fonctionne créent des
emplois industriels mieux rémunérés que
les emplois de service ne
s'appliqueraient pas à la Guadeloupe la
Martinique ou à tous les territoires
d'outre-mer dans lesquels j'ai vu des
projets industriels très performants
très novateur et créateur de valeur
ajoutée je souhaite donc nous
poursuivions dans cette voie du
développement industriel dans ces
territoires et que l'État puisse
continuer à soutenir des projets
d'infrastructure stratégiques pour le
développement de ces territoires à
l'intégration régionale dans le cadre
des contrats de convergence et de
territoire les fameux CCT à la fois sur
les routes les ports ou les aéroports je
voudrais renverser un peu une logique
que je trouve un tout petit peu désuète
consistant à enfermer ces territoires
dans des logiques de développement que
je trouve un peu daté pour les orienter
vers des logiques de développement plus
ambitieuses qui intègrent les
infrastructures et le développement
industriel c'est un des points que je
défendrai lors du comité
interministériel des Outre-mer qui se
tiendra le 3 juin prochain
nous regarderons évidemment aussi la
possibilité d'une réforme en profondeur
de l'octroi de mer je pense que c'est un
deuxième axe de réflexion absolument
essentielle avec un objectif principal
qui doit être la baisse de prix des
produits importés au bénéfice des
consommateurs et des entreprises
manufacturières je veux dire plusieurs
reprises lors de mon déplacement je ne
suis pas favorable à la suppression de
l'octroi de mer je ne suis pas favorable
non plus au statu quo je pense que la
bonne mine c'est celle d'une réforme en
profondeur en octobre produit par
produit pour voir quels produits mérite
d'être taxé tout simplement parce qu'ils
sont déjà produits sur ces territoires
et par conséquent il faut éviter qu'il y
ait une concurrence défavorable qui soit
créée et d'autres produits sur lesquels
en revanche nous pouvons maintenir des
droits plus faibles
le deuxième levier c'est d'assurer la
concurrence sur les marchés j'ai à
plusieurs reprises alerter l'Autorité de
la concurrence et la DGCCRF sur la
nécessité d'amplifier nos efforts pour
garantir la concurrence sur ces
territoires
nous disposons d'outils de mise en
oeuvre de droits de la concurrence qui
sont adaptés qui ont été récemment
renforcés et qui sont efficaces suite à
la ville d'autorité la concurrence en
2019 par exemple plusieurs mesures ont
été prises très concrètes l'interdiction
du géoblocage injustifiée les
consommateurs ultramarins par les sites
internet hexagonaux problèmes que nous
avaient été signalés par des députés
ultramarins le renforcement du rôle des
observatoires des prix des marges et des
revenus l'assouplissement des modalités
de mise en oeuvre de l'injonction
structurelle qui permet l'Autorité de la
concurrence d'intervenir lorsqu'une
situation d'abus de position dominante
en outre-mer et soupçonnée et de réduire
le niveau de la concentration économique
sur un marché
cette fermeté c'est le droit de la
concurrence se traduit aussi dans les
bilans d'activité de l'Autorité de la
concurrence et de la DGCCRF avec une
activité très forte de mise en oeuvre
des règles l'Autorité de la concurrence
par exemple a rendu depuis 2008 29
décisions en matière de pratique
anticoncurentielle dans les outre-mer
avec un montant total d'amende de plus
de 162 millions d'euros s'agissant de la
DGCCRF les indices de pratiques
anti-concurrentielles établies en 2022
représentait 18% du total national c'est
donc supérieur à ce que représente la
part de la population
[Musique]
deuxième exemple de soutien financier le
tarif réglementé de vente d'électricité
qui permet aux ultramarins de payer le
même prix qu'en hexagone alors que les
coûts de la production locale sont 3 à 4
fois supérieures ce TRV est accessible à
toutes les entreprises et à toutes les
collectivités cela représente un coût
pour l'État de 1,7 milliards d'euros par
an enfin l'État ne perçoit aucune taxe
sur les carburants qui sont consommés en
Outremer ils sont donc plus faiblement
taxés qu'en hexagone pour compenser des
prix réguliers hors taxes plus élevés et
donner les prix à la pompe qui sont
proches de ceux en hexagone le coût pour
l'État est de 1,5 milliards d'euros
c'est trois seules mesures carburants
TRV et taux de TVA représente donc
environ 7 milliards d'euros de dépenses
budgétaires annuel pour l'État
enfin je rappelle qu'un bouclier qui a
été pris a été mis en place avec un
accord de modération du prix qui portait
sur une centaine de produits process
nécessités qui étaient négocié chaque
année et qui a été étendu à de nouveaux
secteurs j'ai pu constater là aussi sur
place l'efficacité du dispositif
certains souhaiteraient aller plus loin
mais je pense que c'est une première
réponse sur les prix à la consommation
qui est
utile enfin nous mettons en place des
mesures plus conjoncturelles à l'image
du paquet pouvoir d'achat de l'été 2022
plafonnement plus important de la hausse
du montant des loyers revalorisation du
montant des subventions accordées aux
collectivités
ultra marine
au total c'est 19 millions d'euros qui
ont été mobilisés pour la seule aide
alimentaire exceptionnelle au ménage
fragilisés enfin j'ajoute que nous avons
obtenu en août 2022 une réduction des
taux de fret de CMA CGM de 750 euros par
conteneur pour la totalité des
importations en outre-mer vous savez que
cette mesure a été initialement prévue
pour une durée d'un an et je tiens à
remercier CMA-CGM et son président
Rodolphe Saad qui a décidé demande du
gouvernement la prolongation de cette
mesure jusqu'au 31 décembre
2023 donc voilà les quelques éléments
que je voulais présenter à la Commission
en résumé la vie chère est un fait
économique incontestable dans les
départements d'outre-mer nous y avons
apporté des réponses structurelles sous
forme de dépenses publiques de baisse de
taux de TVA et davantage fiscaux qui
sont à mon sens tout aussi incontestable
nous avons porté des réponses plus
conjoncturelles liées à la crise
inflationniste de ces derniers mois et
je pense qu'il faut désormais s'engager
dans une réflexion beaucoup plus
structurelle qui doit porter à la fois
sur la question de l'octroi de mer la
question du modèle économique que nous
souhaitons développer dans ces
territoires et en troisième lieu la
question du droit de la concurrence et
pour moi les trois pistes structurelles
les plus porteuses
sur le ministre je vous remercie pour ce
propos introductif la parole rapporteur
qui a quelques questions pour vous
bonjour monsieur le ministre mesdames et
messieurs je suis à collègues merci de
votre présence ce moment et
effectivement important lors de votre
voyage aux Antilles le 24 mai vous avez
10 très clairement je ferai la
transparence sur les marches pouvez-vous
nous dire pourquoi vous l'avez dit
tout simplement parce que la
transparence est le début de la vérité
des prix si on n'a pas la transparence
sur les marges et ça vaut pour tous les
territoires nationaux il est impossible
d'établir la vérité des prix et
d'établir une concurrence juste et
efficace
j'étais très frappé dans mon déplacement
aux Antilles de voir à quel point
parfois chacun se renvoie la balle en
disant c'est pas moi c'est l'autre moi
je prends très peu de marge moi j'arrive
pas à survivre mon activité n'est
absolument pas profitable la seule façon
d'y voir clair c'est de faire la
transparence et de donner la réalité des
marges on va pas le faire évidemment
commerce par commerce mais secteurs
d'activité par secteur d'activité pour
que nos compatriotes puissent se faire
une idée juste de qui fait des marges et
qui n'en fait pas
il y a un certain nombre de collègues
qui souhaitent poser des questions
monsieur gilet monsieur maillot monsieur
metzdorf en ligne
également vous on va commencer par
Monsieur gilet
oui monsieur le ministre nos
compatriotes souffrent de l'inflation
alors imaginez la souffrance pour nos
compatriotes ultramarins qui eux avant
même l'inflation était confrontée à une
vie chère le panier de la ménagère dans
nos outre-mer monsieur le ministre est
20 à 60% supérieur à celui de métropole
lors de votre déplacement aux Antilles
vous avez annoncé être prêt à une
réforme en profondeur de l'octroie de
mer tout en précisant que son abandon
serait une erreur cet axe monsieur
bénistre qui représente un surcoût de
près de 15% sur les taxes déjà
applicables à doit être réservée
uniquement aux produits entrant en
concurrence avec ce fabriqué au niveau
local et pour tous les produits importés
des pays non membres de l'Union
européenne c'est du bon sens mais les
collectivités d'outre-mer ne doivent pas
être les grandes perdantes d'une réforme
il convient donc de compenser la perte
de recettes pour les collectivités
locales qu'entraînerait cette réforme
qui rappelons-le entraînerait une baisse
du coût de la vie en compensant à l'euro
près via la dotation globale de
fonctionnement
coût annuel estimé environ un milliard
d'euros c'est réaliste monsieur le
ministre c'est réaliste et c'est attendu
par nos compatriotes ultramarins alors
ma question est simple que comptez-vous
faire précisément dans vos propres
liminaires vous semblez vouloir aller
dans le sens de la mesure dont je viens
de vous parler vous auriez raison cette
réforme issue du programme présidentiel
de Marine Le Pen est une attente forte
de nos compatriotes ultramarins pourquoi
ne pas reconnaître que Marine Le Pen a
raison depuis bien longtemps sur le
sujet et pourriez-vous nous préciser
donc l'action que vous allez mener à la
matière merci
alors je suis pas là pour distribuer des
bons les mauvais points aux responsables
politiques mais pour répondre aux
questions des parlementaires sur la
situation en outre-mer il est évident
que l'octroi de mer je l'ai dit doit
faire partie des réponses structurelles
à la question de la vie chère en
outre-mer et que évacuer ce sujet ce
serait vraiment évacué l'éléphant dans
la pièce
je ne pense pas qu'il soit sage de
prendre des décisions sur l'octroi de
mer qui vont contre la vie de la plupart
des responsables politiques locaux je
peux pas à la fois dans l'Hexagone dire
qu'il faut écouter les locaux qui
connaissent la réalité locale je les
témoins même pendant des années et de
l'autre côté elle est aux Antilles d'y
attendait aux Antilles pour le coup
c'est pas à peine qu'on vous écoute on
s'est beaucoup mieux que vous ce qui est
bien pour votre vie tous les élus locaux
que j'ai rencontrés aucun d'ailleurs
n'étant de ma famille politique je tiens
le préciser m'ont demandé de garder
l'octroi de mer
aucun élu local que j'ai rencontré et
aucun élu national que j'ai rencontré
nobody il faut tirer un trait selon
la conséquence que ce n'est sans doute
pas la bonne option et je ne crois
jamais qu'il soit bon de prendre des
décisions qui vont contre l'unanimité ou
presque des élus locaux en revanche il
fallait modifiant profondeur l'oie de
mer oui parce que ce système est
totalement baroque
et il ne marche pas donc c'est très
difficile de faire cette réforme en
profondeur ça demande un travail
technique très approfondie ça concerne
des milliers de produits il y a parfois
des systèmes de taxation qui sont
différents d'un produit à l'autre donc
le travail technique je ne le
sous-estime pas il est très lourd et il
est très complexe il porte en deuxième
lieu vous l'avez parfaitement dit sur
les sommes qui sont très importantes le
total l'octroi de mer est passé de 2019
à 2022 de 1,2 à 1,47 milliards d'euros
donc on ne parle pas de redistribution
de petite somme on parle de
redistribution de Somme qui sont
extrêmement
élevés troisième élément quand on fait
une réforme il vaut mieux avoir un
objectif pas deux pas trois un seul je
n'ai qu'un seul objectif dans cette
réforme de l'oie de mer baisser les prix
baisser les prix baisser les prix bcds
c'est mon seul objectif
quelle est la méthode que je vais
suggérer lors du Conseil
interministériel sur l'outre-mer d'abord
associé tous les élus et de certains que
tous les élus locaux sont associés à
cette réforme en deuxième lieu
poursuivre le travail technique nous
avons déjà commencé à engager produit
par produit pour mettre en regard de la
taxation la réalité de la production
locale ça vaut le coup pour être très
simple d'avoir un octroi de mer sur des
produits qui sont fabriqués sur ces
territoires parce que c'est une
protection et je n'hésite pas à dire que
les outre-mer ont besoin de protection
tarifaire le 3e personne ne comprend ce
que c'est mettons un nom sur les choses
c'est une protection tarifaire moi ça me
va très bien que dans des territoires
qui sont singuliers qui sont plus isolés
y est une protection tarifaire cette
protection tarifaire il faut la regarder
et il faut la conserver
en revanche sur des produits qui ne sont
pas réalisés sur ces territoires le riz
est un bon exemple il y a des projets de
développement de résiculture mais qui
sont très modestes et une consommation
de riz qui est extrêmement élevée donc
moi je veux bien qu'on garde une
taxation à 20% sur le riz là il y a que
le consommateur qui paye donc pour ceux
qui me concerne je serai favorable à ce
qu'on baisse cette taxation chez un
produit comme le riz de façon à ce que
nos compatriotes payent le prix le juste
prix et pas un prix excessif enfin le
troisième élément clé qu'il faut mettre
dans la balance c'est qu'ensuite il
faudra effectivement trouver des moyens
de compenser si jamais les recettes sont
plus faibles les collectivités locales
qui vont perdre ces recettes puisque
c'est recettes de l'octroi de mer
financent les collectivités locales donc
voilà ce que je propose pour une
suppression d'octroi de mer parce que je
pense que le remède serait pire que le
mal et que on mettrait en grande
difficulté beaucoup de collectivités
locales qui sont déjà en difficulté dans
ces territoires en revanche regardez
produit par produit conservez un
dispositif de protection tarifaire
appelant les choses par leur nom pour
les produits qui sont réalisés sur ces
territoires et lever en revanche toutes
les taxes sur les produits qui ne sont
pas disponibles sur ces territoires en
veillant enfin à compenser les
collectivités
monsieur judo vous avez une question
pardon merci mais j'ai président sur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
j'ai ministre pour l'instant nous avons
fait avec vous un petit peu de
prospective c'est-à-dire que vous nous
avez beaucoup parlé et un bon droit de
ce que vous allez entreprendre pour
réformer un système d'octrunner que vous
appelez vous-même que vous qualifiez
vous-même de baroque
les aberrations de notre mère qui est
que personne envisage évidemment de
supprimer ici ces aberrations sont
connues depuis de longues dates de
longues dates par vos services
récemment nous avons auditionné la
directrice générale d'outre-mer qui nous
a
énuméré un certain nombre de ces
aberrations dont la plus choquante du
point de vue économique est tout de même
que le toit de mer était une taxe
protectrice comme vous le rappeliez
pour protéger les produits locaux et que
c'est étendu au fond à tous les produits
y compris ceux qui ne sont pas réalisés
sur place ce qui est en fait une
aberration économique bien en plus le
droit de mer s'exerce d'un territoire à
l'autre il fait qu'un exportateur
guyanais est taxé lorsque j'ai produit
arrivent dans les Antilles par exemple
bon bref donc tout ça vous savez
parfaitement et c'est là-dessus que
porte ma question parce que une
commission d'enquête monsieur ministre
certes se réjouit beaucoup de voir que
son action produira des effets dans le
futur mais elle a aussi pour but
d'établir les causes et de d'établir les
responsabilités politiques d'une
situation actuelle actuellement la
situation est telle que nos compatriotes
d'outre-mer souffrent réellement sur le
plan social et sur le plan économique
donc nous voulons établir la l'arbre des
causes et des responsabilités de la
situation actuelle quand vous êtes
arrivés aux affaires vous êtes tout de
même six ans que vous êtes
occupez ce poste ministériel vous aviez
votre bureau probablement les
recommandations de l'Autorité de la
concurrence qui je les ai sous les yeux
qui déjà préconisé trois mesures simples
pour effacer les principales aberrations
de Notre-Dame
simplifier la grille des taux d'octroies
de mer et la rendre cohérente entre
territoire géographiquement proche de
réexaminer les taux applicables produits
importés pour lesquelles il n'existe pas
d'équivalent dans la production locale
et 3 simplifier le système d'exonération
des intrants donc ce sont des
propositions et élaborées par une
autorité publique sur votre contrôle la
question est la suivante c'est le
Ministre ayant ça sur votre bureau
connaissant parfaitement les aberrations
de le droit de mer que n'avez-vous dès
votre prise de fonction ou dans les mois
qui ont suivi engagés la réforme de
celui-ci pourquoi avez-vous attendu 6
années pour annoncer que au prochain CIM
enfin la question serait posée je vous
remercie
alors pour des raisons qui sont simples
la première est que beaucoup des mesures
qui sont proposées par le doté la
concurrence relève des collectivités
locales je pense en particulier à la
simplification
je pense que ce qui est nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons la
possibilité d'un accord avec les
collectivités locales et je pense que
c'est ce qui doit permettre pour la
première fois la réussite de cette
réforme de l'octroît de mer je rappelle
que les collectivités locales fixe les
grilles et fixe les taux
aujourd'hui il y a un consensus qui se
dégage sur une réforme en profondeur
d'octroi de mer donc je pense que c'est
la bonne la bonne mesure la suppression
je le redis provoquera beaucoup de
déceptions et beaucoup de colère dans
les territoires
le statu quo provoquera autant de
déception mais pour la première fois et
je répondrai précisément votre question
sur le temps que nous avons mis je pense
qu'un consensus peut se dégager sur les
mesures qui sont préconisées par le
traité de la concurrence que vous
reprenez et que je reprends également à
mon compte simplification la Gaye des
taux réexamen des règles de
fonctionnement simplification avec les
collectivités locales moi ces trois
pistes me vont bien et je le dis pour la
première fois il me semble que nous
pouvons avoir un compromis avec les
collectivités locales il faut saisir ce
moment historique
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse moi j'aurais à mon tour deux
questions pour le moment très brève à
vous poser d'abord je fais une remarque
quand même sur l'octroie de mer ne
jetons pas non plus le bébé avec l'eau
du bas je rappelle quand même que si il
faut effectivement avoir une réflexion
par rapport à l'octroie de mer par
rapport à son impact sur les prix je
rappelle quand même que l'octroie de mer
son objet premier c'est de protéger
d'encourager la production locale et
monsieur le ministre l'a rappelé sur le
territoire la cherté de la vie elle est
liée bien sûr au coût de la vie mais
elle est liée également à la faiblesse
de revenus notamment à la faiblesse des
revenus de travail et il faut créer de
l'activité je rappelle que sur un
territoire comme la Réunion aujourd'hui
il y a un certain nombre de filières qui
existent qui sont des réalités si vous
prenez aujourd'hui la viande porcine
pour le lapin pour la volaille la
production local couvre 100% du marché
de frais et je pense que l'octroi de mer
y est pour quelque chose donc ayant une
réflexion
là-dessus mais ne trompons pas non plus
dans des simplicismes par rapport à
l'octroi de mer je me réjouis que cela
ne se fera pas bien sûr sans l'accord
des présidents des collectivités c'est
ce que j'ai compris des propos de
Monsieur le Ministre et je rappelle une
dernière chose quand même au moment où
tout le monde prône plus de
différenciation pour nos territoires
ultramarins l'octrodemer et le seul
outil fiscal si je puis dire qui est à
la main d'une collectivité locale de le
politique alors ça c'est la première
chose que je voulais dire mais question
pour Monsieur deux questions rapides
pour monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit tout à l'heure il
faut encourager le développement
économique mais il faut sortir des
sentiers battus hier monsieur karenko
qui était chez nous a parlé de zones
franches globale nous connaissons tous
les avantages mais surtout les
inconvénients pour ne pas dire les
opportunités des zones franches globales
notamment lorsqu'on fait l'équilibre
emploie créé et coût de l'emploi quel
est votre réflexion de ce point de vue
là quand vous dites il faut sortir des
sentiers battus moi je pense que sur nos
territoires ultramarins aujourd'hui
l'avenir passe par des secteurs
d'activité comme l'économie circulaire
la production de la biodiversité tout ce
qui est aide à la personne donc quel est
votre réflexion là dessus ensuite
concernant l'Autorité de la concurrence
comment expliquer vous que le pouvoir
d'injonction structurelle ne soit pas
davantage appliqués une autre question
très rapide elle concerne elle concerne
les normes et c'est très important en
raison d'énormes européennes il est
impossible aux ultramarins d'accéder à
certains matériaux moi je pense
notamment à la construction de logements
puisque aujourd'hui la construction de
logements est en panne sur nos
territoires et quand les logements
sortent ils sortent plus cher que dans
l'Hexagone pour une population de
locataires qui a moins de revenus que
dans l'Hexagone ne faut-il pas revoir
ces normes à faire des fins de faire
baisser les coûts de construction le cas
de commercial européen limite également
les territoires ultramarins de
développer des échanges dans un cadre
régional que peut faire l'état comment
résoudre ce problème d'équivalence des
normes et lever les obstacles à l'accès
au marché et à la coopération régionale
merci
alors sur
[Musique]
l'équivalence des normes c'est un point
qui était
souligné à plusieurs reprises par acteur
économiques que j'ai rencontré à la
Guadeloupe et à la Martinique c'est un
travail que nous avons engagé et qui
doit impérativement aboutir
de manière plus
générale c'est équivalence des normes
porte aussi
on est la question des choix
géopolitiques qui peuvent être faites
par un certain nombre de territoires je
vais quitter la réunion pour revenir aux
Antilles il me semble qu'il y a des
perspectives de développement vers le
continent américain qui sont
considérables qui passent aussi
d'ailleurs par des normes qui soient
plus rigoureusement respectées mais nous
avons la possibilité là aussi il me
semble que c'est tout à fait historique
de permettre aux Antilles d'avoir accès
évidemment font partie du marché unique
au marché unique européen mais de se
réorienter dans les flux logistiques et
dans les feux de marchandises vers
l'Amérique du Sud il est pas normal
qu'on est encore du café qui arrive à la
Martinique qui viennent du Brésil qui
passe par le Havre et qui reviennent du
Havre à la Martinique or c'est le cas
je pense que le développement de
nouvelles chaînes de transport à la
faveur d'une mondialisation plus
régionalisée est une opportunité
considérable pour ces territoires
mais il faut également augmenter le
revenu de ces territoires et je crois
profondément que les ressources
économiques de nos outre-mer sont une
chance pour la nation française sont
considérables et ils ne sont pas
suffisamment exploités et qu'il va
falloir faire preuve de beaucoup plus
d'imagination d'abord je le redis en
réorientant les flux
vous avez l'Indopacifique dans lequel la
réunion peut jouer un rôle absolument
clé vous avez beaucoup plus à l'est tout
ce que la Nouvelle-Calédonie peut
arriver à développer dans son commerce
notamment sur les métaux rares il
s'agissant des Antilles je pense que la
réorientation des flux pour qu'il ne
soit pas uniquement faire l'Europe et le
continent européen mais également va le
continuer américain sont des
orientations qui sont très intéressantes
deuxième remarque il y a de la valeur
qui peut être plus valorisée tout ce que
vous avez dit sur la biodiversité
notamment est un trésor qui va au XXIe
siècle prendre un prix encore plus élevé
je pense qu'il est aujourd'hui dans les
balbutiements son exploitation et qu'on
peut en tirer une valeur beaucoup plus
importante pour avoir une meilleure
rémunération de nos compatriotes sur ces
territoires
troisième chose je n'exclurai pas
l'industrie de nos réflexions au
contraire
mais si on veut faire de l'industrie il
faut investir sur une infrastructure et
pour moi la priorité c'est notamment le
développement portuaire dans les
Antilles la roue de côtière qui a été
réalisée à la Réunion vont aussi être un
avantage considérable mais tout ce qui
permettra d'avoir des infrastructures de
qualité plus puissantes et plus efficace
va permettre d'avoir en bout de chaîne
des salaires plus élevés le projet que
je soutiens le plus sous Antilles ce
sont les pores l'agrandissement du port
de La Réunion l'agrandissement du port
la grande mission du port de la
Guadeloupe pardon et de la Martinique
sont deux projets structurants qui vont
changer la donne économique dans ces
territoires enfin dans ces projets
industriels j'ai rencontré des jeunes
entrepreneurs qui ont des projets
révolutionnaires et qui sont réalistes
produire de l'hydrogène vert en
Martinique est envisageable
ça paraît très complexe parce qu'il faut
une installation d'électrolyse qui est
extrêmement coûteuse et très lourde mais
ça fait partie des projets qui à mon
sens tiennent la route mérite d'être
examinée et crée ensuite des dizaines et
indirectement des centaines d'emplois
beaucoup mieux rémunérés que les emplois
de service
merci à Monsieur maillot qui avait
demandé la parole monsieur Gaillard et
ensuite monsieur le rapporteur et
monsieur metzdorf qui est en ligne
monsieur gaillard allez-y monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur
d'abord on est ravi d'entendre que le
ministre de l'Économie favorable à une
forme de protectionnisme et puis
peut-être cela vous inspirer pour
l'Hexagone je vais dans le sens de mon
collègue naïque concernant l'octroi de
mer on estime à la Réunion que le droit
de mer c'est environ 20 000 emplois
autour de autour de 20 000 emplois donc
il y a évidemment un effet très positif
de l'octroi de mer sur la création de
l'emploi et c'est quelque chose sur
lequel il faut être très vigilant vous
avez donné des réponses très claires
très précises concernant votre projet
sur le droit de mer je vous en remercie
j'aurais peut-être juste une petite
question concernant le calendrier donc
elle est calendrier pour votre projet de
réforme de l'E3 de mercedation que le
Conseil de l'Union européenne a adopter
ce même régime de l'E3 de mur pour la
période 2022 2027 en gros comment vous
allez vous débrouiller avec l'Union
européenne si vous voulez réformer avant
2027 donc ça c'est la première la
première question concernant l'octroi de
merde ensuite je voudrais aborder un
sujet totalement différent qui est le
coût de l'assurance vous allez vous avez
l'ancienne mission d'études sur la
surabilité des risques climatiques les
outre-mer font face évidemment une
multiplication des événements
climatiques extrêmes cela pose la
question de la surabilité de nos
territoires donc en outre-mer les
ménages sont plus exposés au
catastrophes naturelles en France
métropolitaire cela va augmenter on
estime que c'est 20% de sinistre grave
en plus à l'horizon 2050
donc pourtant c'est même ménage dans nos
territoires sont nettement moins
nombreux à être assurés on les assure
pas car leur logement n'est pas
assurable à cause de leur insalubrité
ils ne sont pas assurés car l'assurance
est trop cher en gros c'est une forme de
double peine donc il existe bien à fond
de secours outre-mer pour indemniser les
non assurés donc la première question
c'est va-t-il être maintenu ou abonder
la deuxième question c'est évidemment
sans présenter les conclusions de la
mission pouvez-vous prendre l'engagement
aujourd'hui que les montants des
assurances seront stables dans nos
territoires ultramarins
troisième question que comptez-vous
faire donc du coup pour que nos
territoires soient assurés de matière
satisfaisante et sortir de la dichotomie
sur donc surexposition et sous-
et donc quatrième question qui va avec à
envisagez-vous d'inscrire la question de
l'assurance dans le BP
et puis dernier point et j'en arrêterai
là mon collègue Philippe Naïa a parlé
tout à l'heure des revenus on a
interrogé ministre des Outre-mer hier
sur les revenus bon les réponses
globalement n'était pas satisfaisantes
mais c'est pas le problème moi j'ai
interrogé sur l'évaluation des
dispositifs d'allègement fiscaux et de
défiscalisation qui ont lieu dans notre
pays au niveau ultramarin depuis plus de
30 ans c'est le modèle on nous dit que
ça fonctionne on nous dit que ça crée
des emplois pourquoi pas nous on est
prêt à tout à tout accepter mais à
partir de quoi pour l'étape peut-il
affirmer que les dispositifs
d'allègement fiscaux ou sont
favorisent l'emploi à partir de quel
rapport sur quel évaluation je vous
remercie
je vous prie de m'excuser monsieur le
ministre avant que les uns les autres
répondent je demanderai aux autres à
chacun maintenant de faire des questions
très courtes puisque le temps qui nous
est imparti maintenant va se terminer
dans un instant merci et il faut surtout
donner la parole
alors Monsieur gaillard sur peut-être
quelques remarques sur des points
importants je n'ai pas employé le mot de
protectionnisme je pèse en général les
mots que j'emploie mais celui de
protection oui c'est déjà pas dans le
bon sens et je n'hésite pas à dire que
nous l'avons développé pour toute la
nation française
territoire et départements d'outre-mer
comme hexagone et je crois très
profondément elle nécessitait de
protéger nos emplois nos investissements
nos technologies qu'on nous décidons par
exemple de réorienter le bonus
électrique uniquement sur les véhicules
qui sont produits en Europe c'est une
façon de protéger notre industrie
automobile et je pense que le
responsable de la responsabilité d'un
politique c'est effectivement de
protéger ses compatriotes et son
économie
sur la réforme de l'octroi de mer
vous avez parfaitement raison
le régime a été accordé pour les 5
années de 2022 à 2027 pour ceux qui me
concerne je ne compte pas attendre 2027
pour introduire les premières étapes de
la réforme de l'octroi de mer tout ce
qui permettra d'avancer rapidement sur
cette voie là aura mon soutien il n'est
pas interdit de faire des notifications
à la Commission européenne sur le
changement du régime que nous avons
adopté donc je plaide pour que nous
avions rapidement que nous enregistrions
des premiers progrès dans les mois qui
viennent que des étapes soient franchies
avant 2027 et que ce soit notifié à la
Commission européenne en tout cas c'est
la position que je défendrai
sur l'assurance d'abord vous avez raison
de souligner ce sujet je pense que c'est
un des sujets les plus difficiles et les
plus importants à traiter dans les
années qui viennent premier sujet à
traiter vous l'avez vous-même souligné
c'est que donc compatriotes s'assure ils
sont beaucoup moins nombreux à le faire
soit pour l'assurance habitation mais
aussi pour
l'assurance voiture donc on a un
véritable sujet que j'ai signalé aux
assureurs je les ai rencontrés leur
demander placement pour leur dire vous
devez vous mobiliser pour inciter nos
compatriotes à s'assurer davantage
ensuite j'ai engagé une réflexion dans
le cadre d'une mission que j'ai lancée
qui va être conduite à la fois par un
spécialiste de l'assurance par un
chercheur et par une spécialiste du
climat qui vont étudier l'évolution des
régimes d'assurance face à la nouvelle
donne climatique notamment pour des
territoires qui sont touchés par des
événements climatiques lourds et en
particulier par les cyclones si on n'y
prend pas garde il y a un énorme risque
que des millions de nos compatriotes ne
soient plus assurés dans les années qui
viennent tout simplement parce que
l'assureur assure un risque il assure
pas une certitude
[Musique]
toute dépense fiscale c'est une
orientation que nous avons fixée avec le
président de la République et avec la
première ministre doit désormais obéir à
une logique climatique et on ne peut pas
continuer à la fois à chercher de
l'argent pour la transition climatique
et dans le même temps continuer à garder
les avantages fiscaux pour les pratiques
qui sont contraires au climat donc c'est
vraiment cette zone là que je jugerais
l'efficacité de la défisc en outre-mer
et la possibilité de réorienter cette
dépense fiscale
merci monsieur le ministre je donne la
parole à Monsieur mesdsdorf ensuite à
monsieur le rapporteur et à Monsieur
maillot merci très rapidement merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président bonjour à tout le monde depuis
la Nouvelle-Calédonie il fait un peu
plus tard que chez vous
monsieur le mini j'ai quelques questions
concernant la Nouvelle-Calédonie tout
d'abord je voudrais dire que je partage
tout à fait l'orientation qui est la
vôtre sur la création de valeur je crois
que c'est la meilleure solution pour
lutter contre la vie chère c'est de
donner du travail et du travail bien
rémunéré à nos ressortissants dans ce
cadre j'ai trois questions précises à
vous poser votre projet de loi
industrielle je tiens à vous à vous
inciter à intégrer la Nouvelle-Calédonie
dans ce projet puisque comme vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure nous avons un
quart des ressources mondiales de nickel
et que le prix de notre énergie
aujourd'hui qui est au fioul et
rend notre filière peu compétitive et
donc nous sommes en train de passer à
une énergie carbonée vers des énergies
renouvelables pour alimenter nos usines
de nickel et je crois que
accompagnement de l'État sera nécessaire
sur le sujet le deuxième point que je
voulais voir avec vous c'était le
financement bancaire aujourd'hui les
taux d'intérêt remontent en Europe et la
Banque centrale européenne et la Banque
de France diminue les liquidités pour
baisser l'inflation or en
Nouvelle-Calédonie depuis les trois
référendum nous avons perdu 10% de notre
population c'est comme si la France
métropolitaine avait perdu 6 millions
d'habitants et 6 millions qui consomment
qui payent de l'impôt donc aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin vraiment d'un
refinancement des banques à Google
académie de la baisse des taux d'intérêt
pour que l'investissement refaire
reprenne et que la création d'emploi
reprenne également donc il y a une
contradiction avec la politique que
monétaire qui est menée aujourd'hui en
Europe et en France métropolitaine sur
laquelle il faudrait intervenir le
troisième point c'est la question de la
défiscalisation je voudrais tout d'abord
remercier le contribuable métropolitain
pour l'accompagnement qu'il fournit
territoire ultramarais à leur
développement de remercier l'Assemblée
nationale et mes collègues qui ont
prolongé la défiscalisation dans les
outre-mer jusqu'en 2029 je sais qu'il y
a une mission de l'IGF qui est mené
actuellement pour retravailler les
dispositifs de défiscalisation que nous
avons prolongé je vous demande si cette
mission peut venir en Nouvelle-Calédonie
puisque nous avons des spécificités bien
particulières sur les questions de
défiscalisation et serait donc qu'ils
viennent nous écouter et comprendre
comment ça fonctionne ici également
enfin je me permettrai sur la question
plus générale parce que je vais pas
m'enfermer dans dans les dans la
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais plus générale
sur les questions
ultramarines la question de l'octroi de
mer vous savez la Nouvelle-Calédonie à
l'autonomie fiscale depuis très
longtemps et nous avions le même système
de protection tarifaire à l'entrée sur
l'ensemble des produits même sur des
produits que nous ne produisions pas
nous avons enlevé cette protection
tarifaire pour les produits que nous ne
produisons pas
il y a quelque chose sur lequel je
voudrais vous alerter c'est que lorsque
nous avons abaissé cette protection
tarifaire lorsque nous avons mis cette
impôt ou cette taxe à zéro sur les
produits que nous ne produisions pas ça
ne s'est pas retrouvé dans le pouvoir
d'achat du consommateur puisque les
importateurs grossissent en garder la
marche pour eux donc si vous deviez
revoir l'octroi de mer et la diminution
de certaines taxes à l'entrée n'oubliez
pas surtout de contrôler les
importateurs et les grossistes parce que
sinon ça ne se retrouvera pas dans le
pouvoir d'achat de nos ressorts voilà je
vous remercie
beaucoup alors d'abord sur le projet de
loi industrie verte moi je confirme que
je souhaite qu'il y ait des dispositions
spécifiques à l'Outre-mer dans ce projet
de loi
ces dispositions peuvent et doivent
évidemment porter sur l'industrie en
Nouvelle-Calédonie notamment sur
l'industrie du nickel BPI France a lancé
à ma demande des dispositifs pour aider
des entreprises à s'alimenter en énergie
renouvelable plutôt que s'alimenter en
énergie fossile nous avons mis en place
une garantie publique qui couvre les
contrats de long terme pour toutes les
usines qui se réorientent vers des
énergies renouvelables plutôt que la des
énergies fossiles ce dispositif sera
opérationnel en septembre il sera
évidemment ouvert à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
sur le financement bancaire
malheureusement les pouvoirs du milieu
des finances sont grands mais ils ne
concerne pas les taux d'intérêt qui
relèvent de la politique monétaire
indépendante de la Banque centrale
européenne donc là dessus mes moyens
d'actions sont nuls en revanche je
voudrais rebondir sur une remarque que
vous avez faite qui est très importante
sur la baisse de population je pense que
c'est un des défis absolument
considérable pas de tous les territoires
mais d'un certain nombre de territoires
ultramarins c'est vraiment Martinique
4000 personnes en moins par an
c'est un vrai sujet de préoccupation des
jeunes qui partent en se disant que ils
vont faire leur avenir ailleurs il faut
impérativement pour ça créer des emplois
des emplois qualifiés bien rémunérés et
des perspectives économiques dans ces
territoires
je suis à défiscalisation bien la
mission se rendra en Nouvelle-Calédonie
je m'assurer qu'elle se rendent en
Nouvelle-Calédonie je serai très heureux
d'ailleurs de l'accompagner dans votre
territoire qui est magnifique je me suis
rendu à plusieurs reprises enfin sur le
droit de mer vous soulignez un point qui
est très important qui fait que j'ai
toujours été très réservé sur les bests
taux de TVA sur les prix à la
consommation pour une simple et bonne
raison c'est qu'en général ça ne finit
jamais dans la poche du consommateur et
c'est un des grands défis sur le droit
de mer c'est de s'assurer que si par
exemple on baisse le droit de mer sur le
riz c'est pas le grossiste ou
l'importateur qui prend la marge donc ça
doit faire partie impérativement de nos
réflexions
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci je reviens sous les marges je
voulais savoir si vous avez des éléments
précis sur la question des marges et
notamment l'accumulation des marges
qu'est-ce que le ministère des de
l'Économie des Finances a pu mettre en
place sur la question de la
concentration des oligopoles et des
monopoles dans cette territoire là
sachant que comme il y a moins de
concurrence cela veut dire qu'il y a
plus de concentration et donc une
consolidation de ces concentrations
aussi bien vérotical co horizontal je
voudrais mettre une grande nuit en sa la
nuance que vous avez mis sous
l'inflation qui est moins dans nos
territoires c'est parce que nous ne
partons pas de la même base de référence
quand il y a 0 influence inflation en
France hexagonale au départ il a déjà
40% d'inflation dans les Territoires
d'Outre bien structurellement parlant et
vous avez dit que la probablement
structurelle effectivement et donc il
faut rajouter ensuite l'inflation
conjoncturelle qui vient ajouter
sur coup x excessif aujourd'hui et on
voit bien
la situation dans nos territoires par
rapport à cela vous avez parlé de
garantir la concurrence les observateurs
des prix d'image et des revenus ont zéro
éléments sur les marges et les revenus
par manque de moyens le délégué un
ministériel à la concurrence et isoler
seul
et ne plus rien faire les jonctions
structuelles et très insuffisamment
utilisé ça veut dire que il n'y a pas de
moyens concrets malgré les indicateurs
que vous avez donné qui permettent de
mettre à jour la réalité de tous les
mécanismes de transfert de marge de sur
marge et surtout d'accumulation des
marges donc que comptez-vous faire
concrètement pour régler ce problème
d'autre part on parle beaucoup de
l'octroi de mer mais la fiscalité c'est
aussi la TVA il y a un milliard deux ou
de TVA récoltés sous nos territoires dit
ultramarins c'est un Milliardo repartent
c'est-à-dire que c'est la richesse créée
sur le territoire mais qui échappe au
territoire que comptez-vous faire pour
que dans la réforme que vous allez
proposer qui ne doit pas concerner qu'un
morceau mais à mon avis une vision
globale de la situation que l'argent
récupéré par la TVA puisse rester et
être injecté dans ces territoire et puis
une question très concrète il faut
augmenter la concurrence parce que on
sait que la concurrence est faible dans
beaucoup de domaines dans quasiment tous
les domaines nous avons pour vous avec
cette un député la création d'une
quatrième compagnie aérienne dans le
cadre de la continuité territoriale
pouvez-vous soutenir ce projet parce que
plus de compagnie c'est plus de place et
donc ça peut faire baisser les coûts les
prix de vente en tout cas et donc je
voulais avoir votre avis puisque c'est
une fiche qui a été déposée dans le
cadre du sium je sais pas si elle serait
analysé mais c'est une question qui est
posée très concrètement merci
merci beaucoup d'abord nous partageons
totalement la volonté de mettre plus de
concurrence sur les territoires
d'outre-mer et d'éviter les
concentrations les fènes de
concentration qui conduisent
nécessairement à des surcos
je pense très sincèrement que le
nécessaire est fait que pour toujours
faire davantage mais que le nécessaire
est fait d'abord nous avons une analyse
en matière de transparence des marges
ciblées et ponctuel la plus approfondie
possible qui est faite par
l'Observatoire des prix et des marges on
peut encore accélérer son travail leur
demander d'aller plus loin je prends
note de votre remarque et nous ferons le
nécessaire pour que ces analyses soient
plus approfondies ensuite nous avons
passé des instructions très claires à la
DGCCRF pour avoir une vigilance accrue
sur toutes les pratiques
anti-concurrentielles c'est le rôle de
l'UGC CRS c'est aussi le rôle de de la
concurrence quand je regarde depuis 2008
c'est à dire depuis 14 ans 15 ans
l'Autorité de la concurrence à mener 68
décisions de contrôle des concentrations
en outre-mer ce qui est un chiffre
important enfin je rappelle que le seuil
applicable pour le contrôle des
concentrations a été abaissé en
outre-mer et le 5 millions d'euros
contre 15 millions d'euros dans
l'Hexagone moi je suis ouvert à toute
proposition pour aller plus loin ce que
je partage cette volonté de mettre de la
concurrence parce que c'est ce qui fait
baisser les prix je pense qu'il y a déjà
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
nous sommes évidemment ouvert à toutes
les améliorations et à tous les
renforcements possibles
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
maillot et après monsieur castor merci
bonjour je suis un collègue bonjour
monsieur le ministre vous venez de dire
que vous êtes favorable à ce qu'il y ait
plus de concurrence entre ce que vous
dites et ce qui est fait il y a une
sacrée différence parce que au sortie
des gilets jaunes c'était tout un
symbole pour nous l'État a donné son
aval pour que le groupe Ayotte rachète
le groupe vademia donc de mettre la
Réunion en situation géopolistique je ne
peux pas commencer mon propos sans
répondre à monsieur mesdorf qui remercie
le contribuable français
de la fin qui demande à ce qu'on
remercie le contribuable français je
juste lui dire en espérant qu'il m'a
entendent encore qu'il y a aussi des
contribuables dans les outre-mer et on a
payé des impôts à l'époque nous si on
refait l'histoire de notre sang et de
nos transpirations maintenant j'y viens
à ma question j'avais déjà interpellé
votre collègue Olivia Grégor il y a un
mois sur le prix notamment le prix de la
grande distribution notamment sur le bqp
et le bqp plus qui a eu reçu un à ces
modestes c'était une montagne qui a
couché d'une souris pour nous celle-ci
avec beaucoup de sincérité à reconnaît a
reconnu qu'elle ne peut pas le répondre
à cela en deux minutes et
rendez-vous a été fixé d'ici là monsieur
le ministre au grand mot les grands
remèdes pensez-vous que les mesures de
compensation prises en urgence est
nécessaire à ce qu'il y a pas le
ministre que vous êtes est-ce que vous
ne pouvez pas vous prendre une décision
d'urgence comme je l'ai dit au grand mot
grand remède sur le coût de l'inflation
et je rejoins mon collègue à Jean que
quand vous vous découvrirez l'inflation
nous ça fait déjà 20 ans 25 ans voire
même 40 ans qu'on y est et de régler les
solutions de du coût de la vie des
produits d'alimentation ne règlera pas
le problème de fierté dans dans nos pays
d'outre-mer ai-je besoin de le rappeler
ici en lieu et place que les frais
bancaires à la Réunion ça frôle le vol
si ça n'est pas déjà c'est 65% plus cher
dans nos territoires qu'en métropole
pour communiquer ces 12% plus cher les
voitures électriques donc vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure et nettement voir
quasiment plus cher chez nous
que en métropole en hexagone je veux
vous dire un message qui vient tout
droit des autres mères on ne veut plus
se faire voler parce que nous c'est
comme ça qu'on le vit en dans les autres
mères quand on achète à manger on se
fait voler quand on s'habille on se fait
voler quand on communique on se fait
voler et quand on se déplace on se fait
voler donc il faut trouver des mesures
d'urgence puis des mesures sur le long
terme mais on est en train de crever la
bouche ouverte et c'est de mesures
d'urgence qu'il faut trouver en lui et
place et dès maintenant
oui je vais très sincère avec vous comme
durant toute cette audition
la seule vraie mesure contre l'inflation
c'est la conjonction d'une politique
monétaire efficace et d'une politique
budgétaire responsable et c'est la ligne
à laquelle nous sommes tenus depuis deux
ans avec en plus des mesures de
protection politique monétaire tout
simplement parce que si les prix
explosent c'est qu'il y a un sujet sur
l'énergie renforcé par la guerre en
Ukraine et par les goulets des
tremblements sur les chaînes de valeur
vous voulez des tremblements qui
touchent en particulier des territoires
comme la réunion les territoires
ultrama si on veut éviter
que l'inflation persiste voit augmente
il faut que l'argent soit plus cher
c'est taux d'intérêt avec les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur
l'activité économique donc c'est un
dosage à trouver et il faut éviter
d'avoir une politique budgétaire
expansionniste qui alimente l'inflation
ce qui n'exclut pas les mesures de
protection que vous avez indiquées le
bqp le bq+ j'ai demandé Olivia Grégoire
de faire un rapport très précis sur
l'efficacité du bqp plus sur les
territoires
ultramarins et elle reviendra vers vous
sur ce sujet après chacun des points que
vous avez mentionné que ce soit sur les
frais bancaires sur les véhicules
électriques méritent aussi l'examen s'il
est un sujet spécifique sur les frais
bancaires moi ça me pose aucune
difficulté de convoquer la Fédération
Bancaire Française de parler des frais
bancaires en outre-mer et de dire là on
a une vraie difficulté on traite sujet
par sujet secteur d'activité par secteur
d'activité
monsieur castor oui bonjour cher
collègue bonjour monsieur le ministre je
vais vous parler de la Guyane
et de ses paradoxe
la balance commerciale de la Guyane
c'est plus de 90% d'importation
et quasiment pas d'exportation
moi je pense que sur la question des
prix il y a quand même juste équilibre à
trouver et tant qu'on n'ira pas vers une
économie endogène je pense pas qu'on
sortira de des problèmes structuels or
la Guyane c'est une terre de ressources
énormes au moment où je vous parle il y
a une exploitation du pétrole et du gaz
au Guyana on dit que dans trois ans le
PIB par tête d'habitants Guyana
dépassera celui de la France les
chiffres du FMI et de la Banque mondiale
c'est-à-dire que sur le plateau
d'aiguillages nous savons tout ce qu'il
y a du pétrole et du gaz et y compris
chez nous de la zone maritime de la
Guyane sauf qu'il y a eu la loi Hulot
qui nous interdit toute possibilité
d'exploitation au nom de des questions
environnementales et des enjeux
environnementaux sauf que la même
entreprise multinationale française
totale exploitent dans les eaux de nos
voisins qui a quand même un paradoxe
c'est demain s'il y a même des problèmes
de sûreté ou de sécurité la Guyane sera
tout de suite impactée
ce sont des phénomènes extrêmement
importants puisque du côté du nord-est
du Brésil vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
aussi que petrobrass avec d'autres
consortium s'apprête eux aussi à
exploiter le pétrole
et le gaz
donc je veux vous je vais vous
simplement vous dire que moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait j'aimerais avoir
votre avis une conférence vraiment
spécifique sur l'économie de la Guyane
et comment on peut à partir de nos
ressources là j'ai parlé du pétrole et
du gaz mais c'est la biodiversité c'est
la forêt c'est etc or toutes les
politiques publiques ont été menées pour
la Guyane ont été des politiques
publiques de Miss sous-cloche de notre
territoire avec un autre paradoxe c'est
à dire pendant que nous n'exploitons pas
nos ressources et bien les garennes
Perros par exemple dans le cas de
l'homme depuis près de 40 ans
sortent environ les chiffres officiels
de la préfecture
10,5 tonnes d'or c'est à dire quasiment
l'équivalent de du budget de la
collectivité territoriale
chaque année
et donc là je parle de l'or je peux vous
parler de notre milieu halieutique
c'est-à-dire de la pêche avec l'activité
illégale qu'il a aussi donc
fait autant de dégâts sans que nous n'en
récoltons
quoi que ce soit je rappelle qu'il y
avait 150 opérateurs miniers à l'époque
il ne reste plus que 15 des opérateurs
légaux que nous avions presque 200
chalutiers qui pêchaient la crevette que
nous avions le marché de des États-Unis
le marché du Japon le marché de la Corée
et que nous sommes passés aujourd'hui à
peine 6 chalutiers
donc je veux pas trop m'étaler je pense
que la Guyane est une terre vraiment qui
a des réalités totalement différentes de
tous les autres territoires et notamment
de nos collègues de l'outre-mer je ne
vois pas comment si nous sommes sérieux
dans les politiques publiques qu'on
construites mener
qu'on puisse le faire sans un engagement
très fort particulier et qui tiennent
compte de tous ces atouts que nous avons
ce que je pense que pour le reste
l'économie sous perfusion avec la
commande publique que nous sommes
arrivés au bout de ce schéma là d'autant
plus que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
nous avons une croissance démographique
hors normes les chiffres de l'INSEE qui
sont en deçà de la réalité vous le savez
annonce que
nous sommes aujourd'hui à peu près 300
000 habitants officiellement tous les
éléments que nous recoupons avec les
collectivités territoriales nous pensons
que nous sommes plutôt à 450 000
habitants avec toutes les difficultés
que ça apporte pour les collectivités
territoriales qui n'ont pas les
dotations les déchets qui correspond à
la réalité puisque il faut quand même
mettre ses enfants là dans les écoles
etc etc et les fois il faut que les
équipements publics et en 2040 ce qui
est prévu par l'Insee les chiffres
officiels c'est 570000 habitants donc
les décisions elles doivent être prises
urgemment pour pouvoir donc
effectivement
de façon assez radicale aller vers un
schéma inverse et nous permettent d'user
de profiter de nos ressources naturelles
et aller vers une économie endogène
et je pense que c'est que comme ça qu'on
pourra sur les questions donc du coup de
la vie en tous les cas avoir un point
d'équilibre entre les enjeux
environnementaux la nécessité de
développement comme une du territoire de
l'aménagement du territoire d'avoir une
économie qui permette donc d'avoir de la
redistrie de la redistribution et ne pas
dépendre donc de cette économie sous
perfusion
merci monsieur le ministre
je partage tout ce que vous avez dit je
reviendrai juste sur la question des
hydrocarbures ma proposition est de me
rendre en Guyane dans les mois qui
viennent pour avoir cette discussion sur
l'avenir économique de la Guyane la
Guyane est un territoire qui a des
particularités très singulières par
rapport à toutes les autres outre-mer
d'abord vous avez des frontières avec
des pays qui sont très puissants très
nombreux vous avez des frontières avec
des pays qui
porosité qui est totale je me souviens
de mettre rendu à papa ishton je pense
qu'on voit très concrètement ce que
c'est que la porosité de la frontière et
que Suriname en réalité il n'y a pas de
frontière
et en troisième lieu vous avez une
croissance démographique qui est
exponentielle donc tout ça crée des
singularités
j'entends parfaitement ce que vous dites
sur les
hydrocarbures et le sentiment
d'injustice que cela peut créer il reste
que le choix national qui a été fait je
crois qu'elle était fait par la nation
française c'est d'arrêter toute
recherche et exploitation
d'hydrocarbures donc je pense que c'est
un choix qui engage aujourd'hui
tous nos compatriotes sur quelques
territoires qu'ils soient et qu'il y a
plus de valeur à trouver dans
l'accompagnement de la transition
climatique et la valorisation d'autres
ressources la Guyane plutôt que de se
lancer dans l'exploitation l'exploration
de champs hydrocarbures et d'énergie
fossiles qui détruisent la planète mais
ça ce sont des choix totalement
structurants
troisième remarque
je rejoins totalement ce que vous dites
sur le développement endogène l'idée de
la mise sous cloche d'avoir des
politiques publiques très artificielles
ça ne marche pas et ça ne marchera pour
aucun territoire aucun territoire
d'abord je trouve que c'est à la limite
d'être injurieux de voir exactement
voilà ce qui est bon pour votre
territoire non les territoires savent
très bien que ce soit la Martinique la
Guadeloupe la Réunion la
Nouvelle-Calédonie où la Guyane ils
savent très bien sur quelle base de
développement ils veulent avancer et je
vous le dis je fais des années des
années que je me rends avec beaucoup de
plaisir entre-mères j'étais très frappé
dans mon déplacement les Antilles de
voir que un les territoires regorgeaient
de projet et deux c'était des projets
totalement structurants pour le 21e
siècle c'est pas des micro projets pour
les six mois à venir c'est une vraie
orientation géopolitique des choix
économiques de ces territoires
l'ouverture vers l'Amérique la
réorientation des flux le partage entre
le transit maritime de long terme et le
cabotage tout ça c'est des vrais
réflexions géopolitiques qui sont
approfondies qui sont solides et qui
sont créatrices de valeur il faut faire
la même chose pour la Guyane moi je suis
prêt à m'y rendre prêt à regarder avec
vous quelles sont les perspectives de
développement et la puissance publique
doit accompagner vos choix mais ne pas
faire les choix à votre place parce que
ça ça marchera jamais
donc accompagnez vos choix aux antiens
ça ça nous paraît très intéressant
travaillons ensemble quels sont les
dispositifs dont vous avez besoin pour
le développer et avançons dans cette
direction quand vous parlez de la pêche
et de la biodiversité ce sont évidemment
pour la Guyane notamment avec l'espace
forestier des perspectives de
développement qui sont très
intéressantes qu'est-ce qui peut
favoriser ce développement combien ça
coûte quels sont les problèmes de
formation quels sont les problèmes de
qualification quels sont les
investissements qui sont nécessaires
c'est tout ça qu'il faut regarder je
vous le redis moi je suis prêt à venir
sur place pour en discuter avec vous et
avec les acteurs locaux
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
oui les comptes des grands groupes ne
sont pas publiés
que comptez-vous faire pour leur imposer
alors que c'est une obligation légale de
la loi que comptez-vous faire pour leur
imposer de publier le compte
conformément à la loi pour les
observateurs des prix des marges des
revenus ils n'ont pas ni la compétence
ni le pouvoir directement d'avoir accès
librement aux marges et aux revenus que
comptez-vous faire justement pour régler
ce problème là d'autre part vous n'avez
pas répondu clairement la question de la
consolidation des concentrations et de
la priorité des moyens que vous allez
donner parce que vous semblez être
satisfait du niveau de contrôle des
indicateurs donnés sauf que ces
indicateurs sont fait quasiment sans
moyens donc comptez-vous augmenter les
moyens pour permettre justement à l'état
d'assurer la transparence nécessaire la
visibilité nécessaire et la mesure
actualisée
de la consolidation des concentrations
verticale et horizontale le territoire
insulaire captif contenu d'un certain
nombre de critères que vous avez évoqué
et puis vous n'avez pas répondu à la
quatrième compagnie aérienne pour
augmenter la concurrence êtes-vous
favorable à cette à cet accompagnement
pour la création de cette compagnie
aérienne et puis comptez-vous recevoir
le délégué à la concurrence et quelle
place vous allez lui donner justement
pour qu'il puisse assuer pleinement sa
mission
vis-à-vis de l'augmentation de la
concurrence dans notre territoire
c'est le ministre
alors sur les comptes des grands groupes
moi je suis évidemment tout à fait
favorable leur publication mais je
rappelle que ça allait du tribunal de
commerce donc ce tribunal de commerce
qu'il faut saisir si on veut obtenir la
publication des comptes des grands
groupes s'agissant de l'accès au prix la
DGCCRF et elle seule accès à d'autres
sources que les comptes qui sont publiés
pour effectuer les contrôles je pense en
particulier au lias fiscal ce qui lui
donne des moyens d'investigation qui
sont plus poussés donc à la suite de
cette audition je demanderai à DG CRF de
faire preuve de la plus grande diligence
sur l'examen des liasses fiscales pour
que on puisse approfondir effectivement
l'examen de ces données et vous donner
tous les éléments de manière très
transparente sur les prix
même chose la consolidation des
des
entreprises je n'ai pas vu l'Autorité de
la concurrence sur ce sujet
spécifiquement mais je peux très bien
voir prochainement le directeur
d'autorité de la concurrence et voir
avec lui comment est-ce que nous pouvons
améliorer la situation
excusez-moi sur les observatoires des
prix d'image et du revenu je vous
interroger sur les marges et les revenus
passionnés
mais n'a pas le pouvoir d'aller
contrôler les marges et les revenus des
entreprises c'est une aberration et
incroyable mais qui réel et je vous ai
parlé également du délégué
interministériel à concurrence pas de
l'Autorité de la concurrence sur la
question de l'augmentation de la
concurrence
et puis la quatrième compagnie aérienne
alors la difficulté que nous avons sur
les marges c'est que là vous touchez au
secret des affaires donc c'est très
compliqué d'aller donner les marges de
chaque entreprise
mais pas la possibilité ni le droit de
divulguer les marges de chaque
entreprise c'est ce qui fait la
prospérité d'une entreprise donc on peut
contrôler les prix on peut contrôler les
marges on ne peut pas rendre public les
marges de chaque entreprise
et faisons très attention parce que si
on va trop loin dans la transparence sur
les marges la réalité c'est toute
l'activité économique que vous menacez
sur l'aérien je rappelle que nous avons
aujourd'hui une problématique qui est
assez différente qui est d'éviter la
disparition d'une compagnie donc je veux
bien qu'on essaie de rajouter une
compagnie supplémentaire mais qu'il
s'agisse d'air australes et de corsaires
nous avons fait
tout le nécessaire et même plus que le
nécessaire pour sauver des entreprises
qui sinon depuis 2020 aurait disparu
alors s'il y a bien un sujet sur lequel
les pouvoirs publics sont allés très
loin je pense même que certains diraient
trop loin c'est sur le soutien ses
compagnies aériennes avons mis 300
millions d'euros d'argent public pour
soutenir
erreur Strales et corsaire ils ont
maintenu défiscalisation qui permet de
soutenir l'acquisition d'avion donc
maintenant je vous dis là aussi les
choses avec beaucoup de franchise
s'agissant de corsaires j'ai dit très
précisément à l'actionnaire que je ne
remettrai pas d'argent public si
l'actionnaire ne remet pas d'argent
public non plus
donne la parole pour une question que
vous avez déjà eu la parole merci une
dernière question à propos de la
continuité territoriale més au préalable
rapidement monsieur le Président il
n'est pas nécessaire de faire la leçon
au commissaire du rassemblement national
sur le sur le trône mer personne ne veut
supprimer l'autre mère nous voulons
simplement corriger les aberrations et
savoir pourquoi elles ne l'ont pas été
précédemment bon je reviens à la
continuité territoriale l'état soutien
me fait le ministre la continuité
territoriale ultramarine à hauteur de 45
millions d'euros de subventions pour
pour les territoires d'outre-mer contre
190 millions d'euros pour la Corse
il y a quand même distorsion est-ce que
vous pouvez expliquer cette distorsion
s'il vous plaît
alors ce schisme a été donné
effectivement à plusieurs reprises quand
je me suis rendu dans les Antilles ça
fera partie des sujets qui vont être
examinés lors du Conseil
interministériel de l'outre-mer ce que
nous avons effectivement un sujet sur la
continuité territoriale je rappelle
juste que nous avons je redonne le
chiffre
mi 300 millions d'euros qui n'ont pas
été mis sur la continuité territoriale
avec la Corse pour le sauvetage des
entreprises aériennes Corsair et Air
Austral
s'il y a pas d'autres questions
sur le rapporteur
oui je t'en prie oui monsieur le
ministre le 28
janvier 2022 le gouvernement a confié à
l'Inspection des finances une mission
sur la régulation des prix des
carburants et du gaz dans les
départements d'outre-mer
on a écrit à tous les ministères pour
avoir le résultat de cette mission et
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas de réponse
toujours que la dernière question soit
une colle donc je vais je vais vérifier
ça et m'assurer que tout ça vous soit
bien transmis
s'il y a pas d'autres questions monsieur
le ministre je vous remercie je vous
propose de poursuivre nos échanges à
travers leur voix si vous le souhaitez
de documents que vous jugerez utile à
notre commission merci à tous et à
toutes